presidents from the three main eu
institutions
signed a joint declaration launching the
conference on the future of europe
europeans will be able to share their
ideas in order to shape the eu they want
meps voted to adopt the 5.1 billion euro
eu for health program
which will enable the eu to respond more
effectively to future health crises
the plan will strengthen health systems
and make medicine and medical devices
more easily available for vulnerable
people
parliament adopted the invest eu program
which should generate 400 billion euros
in investments across the eu
it will boost sustainable and strategic
financing in key sectors
like health environment and social
projects
only 50 percent of people with
disabilities are employed
meps called for clear eu guidelines to
make workplaces more accessible and
ensure equal working conditions
the parliament marked international
women's day by underlining the role of
women in the fight against covid19
women in the eu are on the front line
accounting for 76
of healthcare workers